ten
nine okay
seven
six
five
four i thought arena time with the
tournament one thanks so much electric
guy
so now i'm playing title players
i don't think i play the title player
yet today
playing oracle
i'm going to still play this
this gambit
uh opponent's not walking into anything
it's still transposed to a staffer
though
thank you cowboy cookie
okay idea to play g5 and g4
if i give up the bishop pair but i do
have ideas of knight d4 rook g8 get the
kingside attack
like already there's some
nagging pressure
oh
[Music]
i may have missed that move
if i take there's takes
[Music]
good move
i thought it was much better but i might
just be much worse
or it still just might be interesting
[Music]
takes now let's take with pawn
yeah actually it's still interesting
because this pin is really hard for
white to resolve
my cc3
ah white resolve the pin
well played
nh4
gotta try it
he's probably coming
f3 bishop d7
life does go on
pq bombs
do the bomb
i'm only down two pawns
this bishop's really annoying just
pierces through the position
but it doesn't really help defend the
king side
i mean it could though
[Music]
along with the queen
okay
rookie eight
rookie four is probably coming
some idea in f6
okay before i take it
and the plan is h5 h4
okay
intention
india rugged seven
i'm threatening to take in rug h2
[Music]
but not really
maybe queen c1
the rook is stuck now kinda
yeah this shouldn't be so bad
about to get meted there
top
okay dirty time scramble
i mean we were both trying to dirty flag
each other
but only one person can dirty flag the
other person
multiple rooks were hung
i don't feel so great about that
thankfully
i have
facial cleansing towelettes
which have been sitting on my desk for a
while and i forgot about
they're for normal skin
[Music]
um
maybe i'll use them later
wash away the dirtiness
okay a win is a win
um 85 so soon
yeah this is some kind of unpleasant
line
i think i take
probably d3
i'm gonna lose upon eventually so
[Music]
try and get the most for it
okay very positional game
good move
don't fully know what to do here
it doesn't look great but
doing this
i'm not better here but i don't know how
much worse i am
the king's a bit more active
for
some counter play
i'm down a lot of time but i think it
was worth spending that time to
at least get some chances
[Music]
i'm just down the pawn
i should have taken the rook
um
[Music]
this should be a draw
white stroke is really misplaced
okay
i was really kind of the opponent
oh what a good human person
okay
i was expecting to get dirty flag there
is that just a second game
that was the second game
oh is my opponent streaming too shout
out to my opponent
everyone follow their twitch channel
okay
i'll be very conscious of time here
point of a3 is to maybe put the bishop
on a2
target the pawn
now block's building up nicely
that's the free pawn i think
hitting the knight twice
probably trade rooks
can be six in the end
i think i can play queenie two
keep things defended if queen b6
because there's no like great
discoveries there's this or this but
i move the queen again
f4 is a bit weak
um
and i think it's okay
oh
it's not okay
okay maybe it's okay
i think knight c3 was better there
back
f7's attacks
another one of these end games
how the time flies
yeah my time is flying right away right
now welcome back to bella's up
clubbing for five months
there's some mating idea
oops
i gotta go for the meeting idea
let's block defend
there's one way to
defend
that's another way i was thinking f6
the f6 was maybe a little bit stronger
i can win the pawn first
i wasn't expecting black to take on g3
okay plenty of time here
no stalemates
okay
uh
undefeated
got two and then one and then three
no sign of carlson i don't think
uh
i don't feel like berserking
does that make me a bad person
just trying to like not wear myself out
too much
i think this is okay
[Music]
yeah this is a really pleasant structure
i love knight d4 though
[Music]
over b4
queen should be elsewhere
wow
actually queen should be here
of the a-file now
takes
still working
if i give you a prime sub do you get a
better sandwich than if i gave a regular
sub
and depends on the toppings
problem is b5 is weak in these
lines think i'll just go for
[Music]
this
win connect 4 maybe
oh i blundered
[Music]
upon uh
what to do
oh this is about to crumble
i should come to d5
[Music]
this is really bad
wait what
i'm not sure what my opponent was
expecting there
okay that works out
unexpected gift of a rook
i was about to like lose
when not berserking
[Music]
i can lose having time odds
i'm tied with jagalko
nice
yeah i think i don't know if it was a
mouse slip or just uh a misjudged
pre-move
maybe my opponent was expecting
something else
thank you eric
oh thank you
hey it's pam welcome back pam
pam i'm sure you're you're aware i'm
sure i mentioned this
when you were here previously but
there's a pam emote
all the subs can use
the move order is important in this line
is uh 897
there's a line with knight c6
might be similar
though of castling
it's a weird position a lot of tension
[Music]
lots of mess in the center
yeah the idea is to eventually win a
pawn i think i can take here
i'll hit the bishop in the end
like takes takes
and both things are hanging
i'll be up upon there is this move and
then rook d4
oh that's why pam said thank you oh
that's nice
okay emote only mode for this game
because why not
usually it's a viewer redeeming emo only
mode but
i can redeem it too
hey i'm back over 2600
i didn't even realize
i guess it does help not to lose any
games in a while
okay so that was all expected
rook d rook d4 rook c8
uh would depend
oh there's e5
have this move
you have three put the rook on e2
[Music]
assuming there's some invasion
that's a good move
work see it's coming
it gets weird
i'm preparing b4 but my rook is a little
bit
a little bit in uh in over its head
gone a little bit deep
a6 is a good move
now
[Music]
maybe i can get away with this still
it's really materialistic
ideas to
rook back somewhere
it's super passive
black should have played rook t8 there
possible also active
rook d8 maybe this move
right moment i want to play c6 and trade
hmm
i'm not sure what my plan is
or
i had to prevent this and this now i
over defend this so maybe my
book can free itself but maybe not
c4 and c4 is probably the way to go
i'll lose back upon but we at least got
a game
at a point of
when it's to play a3 and
keep things together
it's a good move
let's play this
well i can't trade rooks
like when the kingpin ending i think
or do i
infusing position
[Music]
that was probably a mouse slip but i
thought it was low on time that was a
cool game
interesting rook ending
that emo only mode lasted a while there
okay again i don't feel like was working
i don't wanna like disturb my rhythm
and last time my opponent berserked and
i didn't berserk i almost lost but
i enjoy having a little bit of time to
think
95 here
okay
[Music]
i looked at this line briefly recently
if this move
just dropped the bishop
g6 h5
it's already getting weird
bishop
looks interesting
couple pawns are
potentially vulnerable
f3 could be with threats
let's go i have two sets of adjacent
double pawns
let's go
[Music]
f3
the thing is after takes i hit the rook
and the knight's still hanging now
knights attacks so many times
or
inside castling as a move
it's super risky
let's try it
triple pawns
next to double fawns look at this
upside down tee
e7 here
this is such a crazy position
[Music]
i still have triple pawns
partial distancing
or d7 i take the rook
oh i didn't see that move
am i losing
oh no that move kills all my
[Music]
fun oh no my fun
[Music]
i might just be losing here
have to take the rook
or
still some hope
oh no
don't hurt me
stop hurting me
don't do it
[Music]
i kind of smell it coming
i'm already set up in decent position
wait for it wait for it the other people
smell it too
[Music]
smelling it from a distance
the smell was very strong there
was such a funny game
i don't know if i get any frozen
trophies for the pawn structure but i
got something for the sail matrix
yeah shout out to the clips channel
if you're watching in the future on the
clips channel
you can also watch live on twitch
that game was so funny there was
quadruple pawn potential there was also
quintuple pawn potential
because i had triple pawns with
two pawns on both neighboring files
it's just such a bizarre structure
okay new new game
so i'm playing this new gambit which
i'll talk about a little bit later
um
it's very similar to stafford gambit
but there's some slight differences
okay so now we're just transposing to
stafford
and white falls for one of the most
basic traps
bishop e3 is really the only move and
then i went back the pawn
you know three bishop d4
um
i should know what to do here
probably queen g5
bishop g4
h5 here
i'm not sure if i'm winning anything
though
and generally it's just a nice position
that
i wonder if i can take
click on e2 with queen e2 bishop h2
the king okay there was king e2 but
the point is if rook takes i have queen
g3 check
meanwhile i just want to play bishop g3
check
knight f2 expected
still bishop g3
22 months oh yeah
much love was wondering what your
favorite genre of show or book is
uh nonfiction actually
a documentary
[Music]
i'm just counting
enough seven i should have enough
counter play
oh it's getting some play though
this first
the queen f7 rook f8
i also have this move to attack both
pawns
there's knight c4 in that line
a queen f5 i don't think i mind
we're probably getting some end game
again
not so simple
um probably not better here
i don't think i'm much worse but i am
losing a pawn
[Music]
g3
i want to invade from behind
rook f6 i do have kiney seven
usually makes sense to grab space go for
some small positional gain
oh
okay it's about to get weird
young children close your eyes
almost two years wow
opposition i'm not threatening meat but
i do this
okay i do have mating ideas
and i'm sacking pawns going for a mating
attack and a rook ending
yeah that didn't work at all
[Music]
okay
i'm in trouble
i'm kind of smelling it again though
the smell of stalemate is so strong
wait i'm not even worse am i
i am
no i'm not stalemating uh
i made two queens
okay that's my first loss what to do
let's sad too his opening was so good
ah i did try
nobody's working i want to say above
2600
or at least a little bit longer
and win in five moves
so even if i berserked i would not have
gotten extra points
the game needs to be at least 10 moves
long i think
i've been so many people with that
this queen f3 move
so many people pre-move bishop e7
okay
moving on
it's a nice way to recover after
losing a tough game
they'll win in five moves
at c5 is a little bit too early because
now black has to play knight a6
and i'll get some structure with uh
a c3 and a4
uvt student
and jamie lemlem two new prime subs
yeah friendly reminder you have prime
you can sub for free
it does help support the channel
you have the prime command
i mean white's slightly better here but
it's not uh not like a huge advantage
just a bit more pleasant
and knight c7 can't be played because
takes and takes and
tactics happen
probably time to castle
okay so this is a threat
rook
and this is also kind of a target but we
defended oh forgot about the pawn
i could win a7 actually
lucy iii
i'm also afraid about this pawn
uh
knight d3
this is actually not so good
i should have
been a little bit more alert there
i mean thankfully i didn't plunder f2
like sometimes when you plunder it can
be very easy to downward spiral
you know i have f
three and bishop d6
come back time
i mean here 95 first
i don't want to take the rook too soon
yeah no need to take the rook
just infiltrating with all the miners
click on b7 now this rook's trap this
knight is also kind of trapped
the queen might be trapped too
trap all of black's pieces
in black's own territory
might be it loses a rook
yeah like everything's crumbling here
wow one two three
a lot of attackers against the queen
oh this was so bedazzling i wasn't sure
what to take the queen with
all right
so that was some nice recovery
a couple london wins
okay
wow provisional reading
really new title player
okay another london
queen c7 it's a ponzac
um this line is still a little bit
tricky though
supposed to play e4 here
maybe queen e2
[Music]
idea to play e4
black play z4
find a way to cope
there's d4 here
not so simple
be some like knight
take on c6
there's queen c4 actually
it allows bishop e6 and we maybe repeat
queen a4 in that line
the queen is useful covering a lot of
pawn targets
okay
so this is possible because b4 takes e3
or that first
i'm probably a little bit worse here
not the end of the world just castle
life goes on
ah down a lot of
time idea is to bring the knight to e3
because these squares are juicy
this is okay
i mean there's knight d4
[Music]
e4 should be fine
it is kind of scary though
i mean g6 is natural
down a minute
i have a lot of supporters on f5
in time i blunder upon
i can't trade queens here
um
[Music]
x
doesn't work at all it doesn't
if it does
not pretty though
getting completely outplayed this game
uh maybe hanging
didn't move
[Music]
it's so unpleasant man
rookie five in the end too
there goes my king
okay
oh that was brutal
i played a good game there
just played quickly put me under
pressure
um
what to do
when can we see the extra footage from
the hikaru slash hanson fight
oh uh
i
don't think i'll be posting anything to
the extra
channel okay playing habib amini
um
play knife six
i had this earlier i had the same
opponent earlier
i played some a6 move
no it was uh the warm-up arena earlier
and a similar position
e5 i take and knight d7
i had the same structure earlier
ah that was a game where my opponent
like mouse slips from rook a1
pre-mover okay one
okay going for minority attack
usually when it's two on three
the minority attack is used to
induce some weakness in in
the majority structure
like b4 is a nice way of trying to
undermine everything
i do have to be careful of getting mated
i do have nada fade if needed
b is pretty standard
preventing white from playing b3 and
essentially isolating the a pawn
there's knight d4 here
doesn't quite work
liking this idea knight c4 i still have
to be careful
but has ideas but i wouldn't mind
trading rooks
paid or not to trade
to think or not to think
okay so b2 is vulnerable back rank there
could be some issues for white
e4 is also the weak
h5 might be coming but then i just take
there's no way to defend the pawn
if my rook can infiltrate
life will be good
e3 is hanging
i might just take on b2
first
betrayed knight c4
[Music]
end game okay three knights e5 i'm
winning the pawn
oh no rook a3 i win the rook
in this case i win the pawn
but still my g5 ideas
looks okay
okay rook b7 rook f8
just can't let the bishop come around
hitting the rook
i'm completely restricting the bishop
it's a weird
thing to get out of though
this move
is to try and trade knights
also threatening this maybe
i don't think that's a threat but
um
[Music]
i'm losing back the pawn but
it's a more pleasant position for black
wait now that's two just wins
i saw this from a distance i thought i'm
just losing the pawn but i'm winning
i'm winning the rook or after takes
takes black
white can't stop the pawn
which is crazy because the rook and king
are in such close proximity
but the pawn would cover
him one
this pawn's in the way of the rook and
this pawn's in the way of the king
that was nice
okay
back on track
top 60
yeah one of the biggest challenges with
esported tournaments is just staying
focused all throughout but
so far i feel in decent form
i can keep doing what i'm doing
here we have some like philidor
fix
play positionally here
a little bit passive for black
between d2 or d1
nothing too special for white just
trying to put pieces on good squares
at some point maybe not f5 or knight d5
potential ideas
with queen two
the queen
hold the center
there's f4
one idea of f4 is to drop the bishop
back to reinforce a pawn and black plays
bishop f8
and also eventually play e5
also this idea
even to go all the way
upon the g6
f1 is pinned
it leaves the king a little bit loose
there's no need to do it right away
oh no my pawn
f takes takes never mind
it'd be bishop f7 in the end
i want to play e5 here
i'll just take in this
e4 takes d5 and move back
might be a bishop
bishop h4 97
anything to look shaky for black
cool idea 97 knight b5 takes in queen
anything wrong with it
i would hit the bishop and threaten some
like full force mates
that's a move
oh the epon's hanging
maybe got a little bit too fancy there
still a good position i think
95
like b4 b5
not threatening to take so
do some lifting
my queen is tied down to defending the
bishop
let's tie down to the thing the pawn
i might play this and then like king's
stock on the g file
now knight d5
85 allows bishop b5
really close to working
i think i'll just go for it
after bishop b5 knight f6 check
if khan take on a seven if takes rook
here
bishop here queen d4 it looks really
good for white
let's do this anyway
that takes time because most of black's
pieces are not helping defend the king
most of my pieces are ready to
destroy the king
some defensive resources maybe but maybe
not
in here it takes takes its mating
ah
that loses the rook
almost clever though
okay feel good again i'm gonna take a
small break
okay two hours left
thank you
princess brah
helping with prime appreciate it
yeah thanks everyone for tuning in
so there's less chat interaction this
stream
but i hope people are enjoying the games
playing paradox
okay
afterwards i'll explain
the backstory of this gambit
but so far there's been a lot of
transpositions to stature
or d5
or
there's also bishop g4 which looks nicer
even
this pawn's a bit overextended
i am down the pawn but white's already
under pressure kind of
a decent move
that playable
that is a move
i can take
he takes
yeah it's a little bit uncomfortable
actually
uh i have six ideas
this bishop is stuck along with a knight
like these two pawns restrict
essentially all of my pieces
all my queen's eye pieces
that's a good move
uh
i take
actually i can take twice
i might as well go for this
and pressure against f2
this is really
really dubious but what else to do
the king doesn't have like a great
square there's d2 maybe
the queen h5 is coming
g6
there's some issues with knight g6
during c5
the queen h5 i do have g6
and the king and bishop might be
fighting for the square
there's cases where i play like c4
now d4
or hinge c4
i might do it anyway though
do it
really quicker
and now these squares are accessible
i'm down a piece and not even for a pawn
but the king is kind of
hilarious
he's gonna hide on b1 now
take this wave first
and your rig f2
this move looks so much more attractive
to take a pawn with check but
i have to think long term all the pieces
want to get involved
not just at night
okay definitely feels like there's a lot
of compensation now
have six coming
i want to enter this diagonal
annoying move
i can take though
now the rook returns
h4
b7 is hanging but that's the least my
worries
unscramble time found a piece but
trying to make do
[Music]
oh
just happened there
oh
oh
good game though
i i should not have given away the rook
i had like a second left though
good game
that was a fun one got some conversation
hey eric thank you for the great streams
if you ever get the chance you should
check out a game called wordemont on
mobile it's basically competitive goggle
oh that actually sounds fun
on mobile i wonder if i could stream it
so what is this line
this move is coming
i don't want to be passive here
okay let's be active
um
yeah it's probably already an opening
success for white
it should be five bishop d7
vietcoin f5
want to put the queen on g6
have some attack
this is some plan
it might work
i do defend the pawn
super risky
also some idea 95
and the point of this move is to just
make white think
idea might be also this
actually this
on the side
making progress here
it feels like the attack is working
my bishops
27
controlling all these squares
if takes takes
because we'll see what happens
on is going to probably come to g3 but
maybe also this idea
of this i do have queen e5 as well
even f6 a lot of moves to choose from
a g3
another five i take in mates
knights kind of stuck and i could return
i'll be down a piece but still a lot of
all the pressure on white
how to handle this
bishop f5
idea bishop e4 remove the knight and
then mate
i can just oh no i can't
interesting move
oh i got my queen over
five
did you have four
or rook f6
very tense game
takes and
this
knight is actually kind of trapped here
there is this this move
five
or
i'm getting funny pawns
they're so funny
it's funny mating idea too
[Music]
doesn't work though
[ __ ]
okay
man i almost stumbled there
really almost stumbled that was a funny
position
i was really
like close to meeting but not quite
i don't think
okay 77
[Music]
calm down
this is a slightly slower line than
usual
probably go for c4
24 ideas
a6 i don't think i can actually take
i really want to sack the queen here
how bad or how good is it
it's not good let's not do it
uh
i'm not so tilted yet uh
back the queen in such ways
that's a good move though
now box playing well
i probably want to play e4 if i get the
chance
interesting
i'm going to just try and chill here
x takes
you curious let's go
let's go
let's also not get hurt
it's really scary
don't hurt me
there's a d5 i take it
black is really trying to hurt me here
i could take the knight and bill out
and this is either a really strong
pawn
it's really strong or really weak
uh we're about to find out
there's bishop
yeah
opposite
six i have to play this move
very confusing position
[Music]
i get a chance i probably want to play
b3 queen b2
the queen's not uh not getting hurt here
oh this is coming
bishop d3
i have three attackers
okay
it looks so passive like my pieces are
all just ridiculous
but there's potential energy
i still can't take the pawn
i want to play this but i lose d4 so
over defend
okay so now the bishop has been
cut off
i've
i have four attackers but black's about
to have four defenders but then i have
a3
everything should be okay
i think
the whole game's revolving around the c2
pawn
one two three four one two three
i can count
one two three four
count to four
all right uh this is looking much better
now
yeah this is a potential energy turning
into
kinetic energy
bringing into trapping a bishop
oh my knight
that's still pretty good
except
not blender anything too big
[Music]
okay i took work man
that was a difficult game
i felt like i was getting outplayed but
it was super double-edged
i only scored one four-point victory
this whole tournament
vladimirovich is leading
is this
oh andreikin
breaking is pretty good at chess
playing scarlet dawn
london time
this line
okay
let's take and do this
there's d4
might be three queen b4 check
that's probably not anything special
i walked into some weird prep
this bishop is sad
i could play e5 soon
pull the d4 square
and open the bishop
a weird move
ah knight e4 coming but then g5
it's okay
knight d4 will be threatening knight c2
being the bishop as well
in text
the queen takes i have bishop f5
92 in the end
it takes takes takes 92 winning the the
knight
otherwise queen here here i have knight
c2 i think
e7's defended
i should have probably played f5 though
the same tactic but then i'm trapping
the bishop
this still looks pretty good
anything better
h5 kg7
going in deep
93 bishop e6
got my gun
maybe i should have played this move
with running rook g3
in each queen's 5 i would take it oh i
forgot about this
i mean i could
i think i should just draw
wait no i can't even defend the rook
oh dear
i got tricked
actually i could maybe
i'll go for this
white has a choice actually
f5 in the right moment
not working
[Music]
outside passer
about 97 man
still interesting though
fix and then push
[Music]
hmm
well played
[Music]
still not over though
wow
[Music]
very well played
just made next move wow
oh i thought i was being tricky but
yeah the problem is knight t8 then i
can't play rook c8 because 97
oh played
yeah rook d1 was not a good move in hsu
is very uh very clever
oh it feels bad
you have to exchange in good position
that's uh nature of chess
still above 2600
approaching the halfway point
yeah my opponent dismantled the gun
okay
moving on
there's a trap takes takes takes and
then i win back the queen
a way more positional game here
i think this is playable actually
because if take 6 i have f3 in the end
always play off three
now takes
and it's still tricky
oh there's funny line queen d4
this takes takes and then i'm
threatening to trap the knight
i'm also threatening rook takes e4 here
removing defender and defending my queen
the rook creates a move
or rexed f3
i don't know what black does here
actually
we can move somewhere
let's move to no this move i take
black might take take uh
f3
you take take and then g4 if i control
the c file
yeah knight is trapped in the center
this almost works this takes his check
that i take with pawn
okay so we play this position
okay
important to stay focused
position's good but
still takes a bit of work
bring the king in first
those pawn is backwards
and these pawns are going to be weak
eventually
along with this pawn
two pawns if takes i take this hitting
a6 and h6
there's some rook check
maybe you should not have allowed that
but it's still winning
top
i had to free the g2 square for free
everything for the bishop to control
okay
and so i've had this weird pattern of
like losing winning two losing winning
two losing winning two losing
how winning won
i win two
or three or four
i think i'm far
so this is a bush gas gambit this is uh
[Music]
yeah this is okay we're not going into
anything
super fun
just an italian
i might go for this plan
initiate f5
so if takes takes takes there's some
bishop tactics
um am i in trouble
do you have knight h6
the queen h5 almost hurts me
i think i'm okay
it's scary though
i think i would like to push push
there's some pressure against f2
from a distance
now this is some idea
rasa queen
like a weird standstill here
at this move
controlling some key squares running to
trap the bishop
maybe rook b8 first
do this first
that blunder is a queen
wow
how long is
no i have a rook f7 though
wait
six takes
i should play this first
like if this i i take with a rook so i
haven't been blundering a queen
you might end up trading queens though
the idea is to eventually play bishop h5
and probably g5 g4
also threatening this random move
doesn't quite drop the knight though
[Music]
rook d1 bishop h5 wins material
upon is pinned
logical
probably want to play bishop f7
mine with b5
knight's a bit out of play but
i think it's okay
let's move now
f2 still a target
every remove
x takes
wow
hopefully
my rook is trapped what
also called bishops though so
[Music]
kill some fights
um
um
go for meat somehow
don't make me though
okay
i was close to winning though i was
close swimming on time
i like how white employed the staircase
maneuver with the queen
like the queen just walked up all the
stairs
and meet me or not it's a stalemate me
staircase just stalemate
that was so funny
okay
that was a draw so my my weird pattern
of wins and losses
comes to an end
used to be ice water
now it's just water
clean cable box
i had a similar structure earlier
be a little bit different
very positional though
earlier i was able to trap the knight on
e4
it's a nice game
[Music]
this time 94 probably rook d1
get the pin
there's also an e7
i think f4 makes sense
move i probably played eventually i have
five ideas
knight t5 is playable here
i mean f5 is very close to
happening
there's 94
it's gonna get spicy
it's our subiversary
hey happy summerversary mark a donk
i take there's rook b8
maybe this move
i don't mind the queen trade especially
if my knight can get into d6
i might be losing a pawn actually
[Music]
and now it's time to just attack
we need two and
shift everything over
king f6
looks good
now queen
he wants to enter
oh i forgot about that
yeah
h6 coming
[Music]
still be okay
i'm just sacrificing the whole queen
side
rook c4 is an idea
hmm
i'm gonna go in this way
just want to target f7
my queen might go back my rope might
come to h4
[Music]
there's this move
take the knight
and taking the knight actually looks
really nice
easier position to play now
it's still tricky
there's some funny lines
of takes i take with the queen
wait no that doesn't work at all
okay
work
that's so funny if it works
know if it works let's try it
takes i take
x and then takes
because there's king
eight nine h6
yeah they just take on a3 knight t6
yeah bob probably saw it and was just
scared
between h6 i take and take
okay now it's
back to being very safe
looks like i joined just in time for
tactics
yeah i still have to convert though with
the time situation
okay
ah
yeah that was some uh there's some fun
tactical lines there it's fun having
another d6 green on e4
okay
raising the rating
still top hundred
thank you dear hunter handler
welcome back thank you think box
hoping for nine months
oh thanks uh mad archedonk
i think i called you markadonk but uh
i appreciate the sub
for one year
playing mud lockoff
i'm not bizworking and i'm not feeling
bad about it
interesting
b4
[Music]
the problem is knight g5 tactic
could take and just uh try and be solid
interesting
that's a funny line
stock c6 maybe when c2
maybe not maybe one h4 though
there's g5 in the end
you can play this
okay
and this looks playable
getting the thing
i just losing after takes
oh no
it still looks interesting but
queen takes was less expected
take on a3 now
i have tons of things but i might just
be lost
big sticks
really not what i want
it's interesting though
oh i'm not i'm not even drawing i forgot
there's perpetual
oh it's so sad okay
the king's still cut off
[Music]
there goes my rook
oh what did i do
is there any hope
a risky line to enter
wait taking left 2 is bad
engine doesn't understand though
it does it
oh it does
it's still fine i'm actually better here
oh i didn't even consider this move
this is so obvious looking at it
i don't know why i missed that
what to do
thank you e-trots
yeah i was so confused by the position
it took time there too
it's still top hundred
import nick up there
[Music]
thank you guys all
[Music]
oh yeah the backwards magnus carlsen is
playing
nestle rock
sun gam
uh no berserking
no queen trade
there is some threat of knight uh
not sure if i can make it work though
be patient
h5
[Music]
the structure is not great for black
because dark squares are weak
and
black only has lights for bishop
looks like i'm getting an h5
if takes take some castling i can take
on d5
i think black was maybe expecting this
this but
yeah simple tactics
i'm also hitting this pawn
so this is a
pork
not over though
okay i can t i can play knight f6
and then it should be pretty
decisive
okay
no simple chess
up two pawns
structure is not ideal but
it's okay
weird tension
[Music]
entirely sure what to do here
this is okay
really
i'm overthinking everything but
it should still be winning
after the b5 fun
i'm so sad now
oh i could have been so happy
that's so sad that's why you don't
resign
oh such a bad
[Music]
what
move
i do thank you gabriel valente
ah
i was playing too like cautiously there
then made a really bad move
it's the nature of a long tournament
just have to try and minimize those
types of blunders
a blunder goat is proud of me
i'm competing for blundergoats title
okay what to do
i've been sticking with the same avatar
and getting decent positions
h6
h6 is slightly mysterious
we've transposed into something where h6
is a useful move
trying to neutralize h file
d4 doesn't work as knight b3
knight g4 is interesting
maybe still
[Music]
an ip3
i might go for e5
and then some knight d4
also some idea of rook h4
there was some carlson game at some
point he played this move
i mean e5 is scary though
it's hard to stop
okay what to do
the other night move
now
i don't know what to do here
play c4
people look so wrong
but it's an attempt of uh discouraging
e5
especially if i can get the bishop to c4
the queen b4 queen d2
now i think i'll taken castle
inside
rook d8 queen d2
and black's probably doing fine but
i'm staying alive
what matters
intention
it takes six takes rook b1
[Music]
b7
if takes there i could consider taking
the pawn
okay
one doesn't work
not a great way of uh
treating this but
it's a safe way
pawns are gonna roll soon
56 kings of bishop
hitting the pawn
bishop there
e5 now
it's still very interesting
f4
[Music]
bishop wants to come here
this looks winning
[Music]
maybe it's not though
what's black thinking about
and i have six i have queen of fade
bishop d3 g6 queen f7 and
it should be winning
i think it's actually force mate
okay
it wasn't easy
i think i was in trouble at some point
in that game
at some point got initiative though
accidental exchange sacrifice
thank you x cerebe
xerabri
new prime sub
okay the goal is top hundred
hour to go
try and finish the last hour strong
do 8 counts
19 months
i'm tempted to agree
i haven't researched in a while
and now we have this uh the bush gas
gambit
uh
still offering a stafford
okay
and knight g3 is interesting
objectively it's uh it's not so good for
black but
we'll still try and have some fun here
[Music]
any way to have fun
i'm allowing the trade but threatening
this and this
okay now we're having fun
lots of fun
so much fun
yeah that works out
at night to the whole tour of that game
where'd that night start from
but sorry from here
okay
yeah the wild knight
i was not domesticated
okay got the berserk win
i'm 90.
optimistical is top 50.
within range like if i
get some kind of streak
okay let's try the same thing
uh
okay still offering the same pawn
deja vu
okay slightly different this game
i had someone fall into the same trap
earlier
i ended up losing
try and redeem myself this game
[Music]
earlier my opponent played knight d1
did some queen g5
this loses exchange rook d2 i skewer and
if king b1i skewer
now there's queen g3 but then bishop e5
oh i also have takes queen b5 intakes
go for this looks more fun
well these two pawns are hanging
and i have queen b1
i'll go ahead and castle queenside
after takes i i check take and defend
the pawn
and then bishop e2 in that line i have
rook
rook g8 rook g2
e4 might be played but then queen a5
check
meanwhile i have a pass pawn
well that's a move bishop h3
untapped
i think i'll just play this
and i do a line with the king but i'm
turning this
due to the pin
[Music]
that helps
i always have to watch out for like
weird tactics but
i just recapture with rook
the bishop h3 is likely
resigning also maybe possible
uh
let's not celebrate too early here
realized
i'm up a pretty clean exchange
a pawn will roll
maybe rock
or the rook trade
so takes i think queen g5
over a minute
uh this move looks nice
writing made in one and threatening this
okay
that was nice
number 70.
oh why do you prefer d4 over e4
i've i play e4 a lot but this tournament
i'm sticking with london
um especially in blitz it's nice when i
can
[Music]
play into uh a repertoire that i'm very
familiar with
i'm capable of playing e4 and
yeah i'll uh i'll play a lot on stream
okay so taking it takes rook here
threatening bishop c7
black really wants to play this oh or
that's this move
attack the pawn
wait
not so simple
let me trade everything
yeah let's trade everything
i have three in the end
brooks come in
this is actually a tempting move
i'm curious what black will play against
it
this takes takes
oh c6 isn't hanging in that line though
i can take on a6
rook
evie queen d7
the c4 is hanging c6 is weak
e2's hanging a2 is weak
if i can win c6 on the knights
undefended
[Music]
uh
in g4
it's still equal material
but black has two weaknesses
i just take
interesting
cake
okay four on three
knight for each person
aggressive
d1 king h2
i probably want to trade rooks
and then try and trade knights
eventually
objectively it's probably a draw but
i'll try and grind the town
you can start walking
maybe not too far though never mind
i have to walk the king to h2 and then
play g3
never mind
man i feel so claustrophobic right now
oh that's threefold okay
i guess i can't complain yeah it's hard
to actually get out of this bind
maybe i should not have like had that
structure maybe you played g3 sooner
um ideally i'd like to try and like
the fight for longer but
what to do good game
[Music]
okay top 70 42 points
playing zer ability
fellow streamer i think
playing a knight's tango
first night's tango of the stream
i might do an a g4
or an h5 f5
even knight d7
and b4
to do this
c6 might also be a move
maybe c5 was more called for
[Music]
uh i don't know what to do here actually
d7 i'm just trying chill for a moment
my rook should be on f8 knight should be
on e8
and then f5 f4
and c5 might be coming
[Music]
c5 i might just ignore it
go for my own plans
it's not pretty
e5 bishop e6
position it's it's pretty rough
still not i have not yet played that
five
but time is okay
my queen doesn't have a great spot to go
i'll try this
okay so it takes
i think i have to
bishop's going to land on c5
and maybe i take on e4
yeah
scary move
okay how do i not lose immediately
it takes and
queen c8
94
i got a sack exchange
just go full throttle on the king side
bishop c4 is coming though
king h is not a move i want to spend
time on
what else to do
i hope
maybe
6
f3
[Music]
i have no time
what happens all my time
good move
oh it's kind of sad
oh i got mated
the game
that was a rough one
uh yeah i didn't choose the right plan
in the early middle game
okay life goes on
40 minutes left
different opening no nights tango
we have a queen's gamble declined
hey it's stephen gray hello eric what is
this about lee chess world championship
ah yeah it's a champion of the world
on the chess
uh it happens every month
there's a whole uh leachate blog post
about it
it was like half joking but also kind of
half serious
yeah four is a typical idea
it's kind of chill in front of white's
face
uh maybe
allowing this and then queen c7
wow
i mean there's a funny line i think i'm
going to go for this
if takes and i have to decide
um
i think it's okay
queen h7 i don't think hurts me
it just gets weird
king will go to e7
oh maybe it does hurt me
[Music]
ouch
yeah i'm getting hurt
there's no reason to do that i actually
have bishop d4 though
maybe it's still okay
i think in kingdom 7 takes takes i lose
a pawn but
this still looks playable bishop defends
the pawn
i can't i mean can i play e5
maybe i
can if i've worked off three
spending too much time here
here this move
the laid bomb cloud threatening to trap
the queen
the bishop still defends
um
ah the tactics almost work
actually do they work
they're gonna have to first
if takes takes a knight defends a rock
but if i take first
i think it works
i dream of this
that's a funny line
long cloud worked out
not sure what white's considering here
maybe just crying about losing material
uh still takes work though
f5
oh in the pawn
eric was born ready richard dratie was
born ready
[Music]
yeah a lot of people like
refer to richard reity as ready
but reity is uh i think the better
pronunciation
let's defend i gotta watch my time
actually oh and my rooks
walk the king in
that didn't work
oh no
push the c pawn
everything's covered on the sixth rank
should be winning still
okay pushing p
plenty of time here
i'm not proud of getting forts
i am proud of
just about converting this position
[Music]
so i built the bridge
time for mating
it's mating season
okay
i always have to stay focused
interesting
i also found an online tts simulator so
i can try my lines before i send no more
poo poo poo poker face
oh have you figured out how to say papa
[Music]
what did i just do i'm just losing a
pawn
[Music]
okay it's a it's a new type of gambit
confuse opponent gambit
i'll keep my
poker face
that's kind of like a smith mora
except much worse
those takes i take
somehow this is kind of playable
it takes takes takes um
we'll see what happens
there's bishop b4
i think i should keep my electorate
bishop
and try and use the g file
like a g
h7 queen b3 hitting f7
not sure if black is sacking b6 or
blundering or blundering g6
we'll take
it the fonz pinned
and now the bishop's pin so i'm
threatening to take here
interesting
there's a funny line
eggs and then queen d4
[Music]
overloading the pinned piece
okay so now one two three attackers
i don't care that the pawn is staring my
king in the face
the box not surviving this
okay so it was worse than the smith mora
but
somehow it worked out
uh oh actually no i can't celebrate too
early
actually a good move
wait this is still weird
i think rook g4
this is still very weird
i'm down a piece too
where'd my piece go
[Music]
let's just be losing i have this move
though
right there there
i think i have to try it
now let's work g4 doesn't even work
try this
oh my queen's hanging
oh it was worse than the smith morrow
how bad is it i'm down to rook and the
knight
for two pawns
i do have the bishop here though
there's some funny ombre soundcheck
on passage
[Music]
it
i'm so sad now again
[Music]
everything is crumbling
okay uh
yeah i think king h7 i'm probably just
losing
that's so sad
[Music]
what to do
still top 100
still above 2600 too
less than
a half hour left
oh lady gaga would be proud
for my pop-up poker face
okay
have an even score against this opponent
mainline
there's a few moves i can play here
there's this there's this there should
be seven is like a trendy
move among super grandmasters
i had this earlier actually e5
i got in trouble earlier you don't play
queen c2 this time
eyeing the h7 pawn
now there there's b4
[Music]
it's materialistic
mb3
blaca center
i'm up upon
probably should castle at some point
before the center opens up too much
hey it's a pawn diamond caller rosen
trophy let's go
okay i'm happy now
even if i lose a game
[Music]
i kind of want to take
pixar's knight t5
i think it's okay because takes i just
moved back and then d-pawn should be
falling
even threatening to work the night and
pond but then the knight
hits me
interesting
good move
[Music]
big so i kept the rook defending the a2
pawn
i have two attackers against d2
i might lose e5
yeah we're just trading oh tactics time
oh no my pawn
[Music]
this is why you should do puzzle rush or
puzzle storm
or read the tactics book
now it's not over i i really had can't
celebrate too early i just won the
exchange but
it still takes work here
um i think i'll put the rook
back on d2
and there's this move too
activate this rook
i had knight e4 as well
uh maybe now knight d4
three
i have to be really careful here
uh f3
i don't want to get stuck
i think i have to do this
um
e7 is a plan
anything can still happen
box running maiden two
i just got a queen side castles with a
skewer on the queen link to game oh nice
sounds pleasant
a castle skewer
okay
check me okay
it really takes focus to
win a winning position
ugm benjamin with a new sub
oh ivy oh i see your link okay
uh there's still 22 minutes left to the
tournament
so if you remind me a little bit later
afterwards
um
i'm gonna
try and finish strong here
oh buzzer
play into
[Music]
the other gambit
should be
here and then here
hi
queen b6
idea
bh6
h5 is a move
well this pawn is pinned so there's no
c3
just trying to undermine the structure
e5 is a bit weak
five's now a threat
might move
somewhere never mind
am i doing
so i meant to play five
still okay
allowing queen e4 but then some
weirdness happens
rook c3 is now a threat
i meant to play roxy too
mouse slipping too much
there we go
that's still my win
okay
i'll slept a couple of times that game
but uh
[Music]
still managed
49 points
gaining a little bit of rating this
tournament
thank you to scorpio 84
the five months
okay playing um pedro gill
[Music]
final 20 minutes
go eric oh thank you kooba
oh what line do i want to enter let's
enter the main line
this is as close as i've gotten up up
poker face
oh that's actually a clever way of
approaching it
uh knight c4 i think is playable
usually it's with the bishop on e7 but i
think the same idea applies
if here i play here
but it's still very much a fight
rookie one
i control the whole third ring with this
rook
affecting the cis
or that
should probably take the night before
this happens
no need to take the pawn
t5 may be coming
i think the bishop is happy here and
then knight can be here
oh
i've worked before
[Music]
did not have a lot of that though
never before
bishop h3 rook h4
it's a weird position
it's queen for rook bishop two pawns
i take the bishop
i think i have to take on e5 first
queen c3
hmm
h4
preventing rook g5
[Music]
i just want to trade a pair of rooks
might end up losing a pawn or two
bishop d5 f3
it's hard to solve rook p8
i might win a seven in the end
if check here here takes here
but then lose a2
all three results are still possible
oh e7 is hanging too
and there's this idea
interesting
leave some tension
a quadruple fork
indeed
i might lose a pawn
go for this
very clever
black can't take on f3
or on e4
the king wants to run away
long there's a b3
it's still tricky though
there we go
okay yeah the pawn on c6 prevents the
bishop from ever uh controlling eight in
like two moves so
okay that was nice
and took work to win that
cool opening idea
i wasn't entirely sure if that's
actually like a good line for whites
hey thank you gary shifting to nickel
nick
hey 66
top 50 is still within range
playing cable box again
uh i guess i'm not berserking
maybe i show the berserked
ah this line yeah we played this earlier
i like the position i got earlier
and keep it very positional
i might have to play queen d1
there's an idea to um
[Music]
say this is us
maybe launch a kingside attack
rookie three
the ideas
small trough queen d6 uh rookie four
repeat once
doing this now
um
[Music]
oh i'll admit i missed that move but it
should be okay
queen h5
it's still tricky
black might not take the rook actually
e6 is a move
i promise my night gets trapped in the
end
oh there's a funny line
i think it's gonna happen queen c7 queen
e7 i have knight g4
i win back material
or do i
i missed h5
well played
i'm gonna have to go into this
still fighting
hmm
this isn't good
okay sure i do have this
not pleasant
[Music]
still kind of surviving
[Music]
there we go
okay
oh that took work to win
and i went wrong with a middle game
attack but
it still worked out
okay trying to finish strong
close to top 50 playing king's crusher
i'll play c5
and now this
uh let's play a line with
rook b8
it's playable
maybe a little bit risky but
it takes
king's crusher wants to hurt me queen h5
may be coming
i don't think it's so bad though
let me try that castle
we trade
[Music]
in b6
a little bit unsettling
[Music]
i don't know what to do here
i really don't know what to do
uh
he's playing so quickly too
fine
i'll just go for this the lights are a
little bit loose
once i got the bishop in action f5 of
95.
that's a really difficult position
[Music]
it could be one i have f never mind
it's about to crumble
it's already crumbling
small chance of hope
wait i just plundered a thing oh no
try this
no time and pretty much no position
uh
[Music]
f3
yolo
[Music]
ichi is really close to working
oh played
oh i got a difficult position from the
opening
shout out to king's crusher
okay final game berserking
all the way
built no time
hopefully not too much tilt
interesting
wow
okay idea e4
both knights are hanging
we have this move
i want the queensland castle
[Music]
box pieces are kind of funny
i don't know what to do
d5 is a bit loose
now c4 is loose
made luft
okay
that's the end
pairings are
closed
that was fun
i hope people enjoyed it
um thanks everyone for tuning in
if you're watching in the future on
youtube let me know if you made it this
far
leave a timestamp in the comments with
your favorite game yeah thanks everyone
for being here
there were 437 players total
i finished in 59th
i gained i gained about 30 rating point
hey 30 rating points on the dots